>> Dana: BORDER PATROL
OFFICIALS TELL FOX NEWS A
MAJORITY OF ASYLUM SEEKERS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER ARE BEING
RETURNED TO MEXICO.
THAT’S AFTER THE SUPREME COURT
ORDERED LAST MONTH THE TRUMP
ERA POLICY BE REINSTATED.
JONATHAN HUNT IS LIVE IN
LEHOYA, TEXAS TO CATCH US UP.
>> WE’RE TRYING TO GET OFFICIAL
WORD FROM EITHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY OR THE
WHITE HOUSE AS TO WHETHER THERE
HAS BEEN A FORMAL ORDER SINCE
THAT SUPREME COURT RULING SENT
DOWN TO BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
AS YOU LOOK AT PICTURES OF
FAMILIES ARRIVING HERE IN LA
JOLLA, EARLY SUNDAY EVENING I
CAN TELL YOU AT LEAST ONE
BORDER PATROL SUPERVISOR IS
TELLING US ALL FAMILIES ARE
BEING SENT BACK UNLESS THEY
HAVE A CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF 1.
PREGNANT WOMEN ARE BEING
ALLOWED TO STAY AS WELL BUT
THAT IS ABOUT IT.
ACCORDING TO THIS BORDER PATROL
OFFICIAL, OTHERS ARE ALL BEING
SENT BACK TO MEXICO IN THE WAKE
OF THAT SUPREME COURT RULING.
WHEN THEY GO BACK TO MEXICO,
THEY ARE OFTEN IN THE CAMPS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN FOR MANY
MONTHS NOW JUST ON THE OTHER
SIDE IN TIJUANA, THE CAMPS
YOU’RE LOOKING AT NOW, FOR
INSTANCE, UNDER WHAT WERE
CALLED THE MIGRANT PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS.
THIS IS CAUSING SOME BLOWBACK
FROM IMMIGRATION ADVOCACY
GROUPS.
A WHOLE SLOUGH OF THEM SENT A
LETTER TO THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT
SAYING THAT HE SHOULD STAND UP
TO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IF
THEY DO REINSTATE THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
THE LETTER SAYS IN PART QUOTE,
AS A SOVEREIGN NATION MEXICO
HAS THE RIGHT TO REJECT THE
REINSTATEMENT OF MPP OR ANY
FUTURE ITERATION TO THIS POLICY
THAT AIMS TO EXTERNALIZE THE
U.S. BORDER INTO MEXICAN
TERRITORY.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO REIMPLEMENT
MPP IN A WAY THAT UPHOLDS HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DUE PROCESS.
AND MEXICO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO BLOCK THIS
DETRIMENTAL POLICY.
NOW, IT IS TOO EARLY TO SAY, OF
COURSE, AS APPREHENSIONS
CONTINUE RIGHT ALONG THE MEXICO
BORDER.
THIS VIDEO YOU ARE LOOKING AT
NOW IN LAREDO, TEXAS, TOO EARLY
TO SAY WHETHER IF INDEED THOSE
MIGRANT FAMILIES ARE BEING
RETURNED IN GREATER NUMBERS TO
MEXICO, WHETHER THAT WILL HAVE
AN EFFECT IN PERHAPS DISSUEDING
SOME TO TRY CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
WE’RE DUE TO GET NEW FIGURES
FOR AUGUST AT LEAST, DANA, FROM
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
PROBABLY AROUND THE END OF THIS
WEEK.
THAT WILL GIVE US THE TOTAL TO
THE NUMBER OF ENCOUNTERS IN
AUGUST.
REMEMBER, IN JULY WE HAD A
RECORD 212,000.
I WOULD SAY WE MIGHT BE
SLIGHTLY BELOW THAT BUT WE’RE
ONLY IN ONE AREA OF THE BORDER.
WE CAN’T SEE THE BIGGER PICTURE.
BUT IT ISS GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT THE
AUGUST FIGURES ARE.
>> Dana: IT DIDN’T SLOW DOWN IN